how's it going
hey you know it's okay what do you got
in your mouth i had combos it's the
pretzels with the cheddar cheeses this
isn't even an ad you're you know the
cheese in combos and i i should probably
research this before i say anything yeah
do you is that cheese that's in a combo
i don't think so it's play-doh okay well
listen so good i want to make sure that
legally we're in the clear but i just
want to get it out there i don't know
what's in a combo but i'd like some
proof that it
was cheese at some point
i know you want one well i just want to
read what's in it
this is a combo you all know what a
combo is ladies and gentlemen it's a
pretzel it looks like a vertebrae
and then uh
in the center is a little little tub of
and then in the center is a as a
cheese-like substance you could put
peanut butter in it i'm matt gurley i'm
the producer
[Music]
coralie in the natural order of things
it's sona what's inside a combo and then
you introduce matt gourley okay that's
the natural order of things i see okay
this is important inside is uh let's see
hydrolyzed wheat gluten natural flavor
coloring yellow five lake yellow six
lake blue one lake those are kinds of
dyes like
yeah l-a-k-e lactic acid citric acid
lactose sodium cassanate so yeah that's
cheese oh
god so tastes like cheese this is an
award-winning podcast is it is it though
we did that it is technically i didn't
say it was merited hmm that's a combo
and you know what that's not bad we are
not getting any money from the makers of
combo i don't even know who they are
stop crinkling the package we're trying
to i'm sorry i'm trying to figure out
who makes combos and they might be their
own thing that's very cool oh you think
it's just a factory somewhere that says
combo
yeah no they've got to be owned by some
massive concern
it doesn't say anything is uh frequent
hold on a second i freaking love combos
yeah hold on a second why are we making
this all about compost this is how
random things are just because you came
in here munching on combos yeah uh we're
talking about combos
yeah this is
you can tell it's just people listening
are like this is too funny
maybe no it's not funny at all it's
awful this is what an awful opening
you're gonna have another combo i know
that no no i'm looking at it i'm trying
to see you're right there's it doesn't
say nestle on it no it doesn't it
doesn't say uh yeah freewheeling combos
right by themselves they're autonomous
shoots by the makers of chevrolet
um i used to eat these a lot when i this
might be too awful in opening i think
this opening sucks let's do another one
are you being serious sure why i think
the bad ones are also still fun
i also i think you're underestimating
the popularity of combos i think people
are going to really love this i think
we're overestimating the other segments
we do on this show that you might
compare this to
okay well i maintain this feels terrible
to me okay now look i like combos i have
nothing against combos but um all we've
done is talk about combos and now i feel
like i'm in a
almost a whirlpool where i keep saying
combo yeah i can't stop talking about it
because you've introduced it listen
i didn't mean to deride that snack
and question whether it's real cheese on
the inside i think that was rash on my
part yes but i'm
certain that's not cheese
well at least we got to the bottom of
something that's really something is
everything you eat real oh come on come
on
no it's not well sona i do hope you're
eating healthy now that you're a mom
you're still uh you're breastfeeding
that's not too personal it's not pumped
before we start a recording so whatever
you eat goes to the twins it does so if
you're eating a combo and it's filled
with lactin diaphylate number five die
number seven that's going to your twins
mikey and charlie yeah it is and then
you wonder why do they glow at night
why are they so easy to see in the fog
i mean is everything that i'm gonna eat
gonna be healthy it's got to be yes you
are feeding these
these lovely little twins yeah they're
six months old
and you're creating the you're providing
the building blocks i know but i can't i
can't eat i love them but i can't eat
healthy for them
you eat pretty healthy i you know i need
a snack every once in a while everyone
does that's not the problem but most the
time aren't you eating healthy i am
actually yeah okay i'm yeah what's the
worst thing you were going to eat today
besides the combos mcdonald's oh oh my
lord wow really every once in a while i
like need it do you get the shake again
that would happen when i would get high
back in the day either mcdonald's or
taco bell and it would be like two in
the morning i'd be like i gotta get a
burger and then before the live show
sona we had time to kill and you went
i'm going to mcdonald's what do you want
and you just went on a mcdonald's
mission i did i know do you think what
taco bell will ever just come out with
an ad that says taco bell it's the best
when you're high would they ever do that
they should they should right yeah it is
is it once i went to taco bell and i was
like i want 50 tacos and they didn't
even
they did they were just like okay do you
need hot sauce i don't know if i've
mentioned i feel like i have but i just
i've never heard this before so yeah my
friend my friends and i we were high we
went to the taco bell we're like we have
50 tacos and we were like oh my god it's
going to take hours for them to make it
it they did not at all react they were
like sure no problem what kind of hot
sauce do you want and we're like this
hot sauce whatever and then we got to
the window and they handed us a carton
made for high people that had
50 tacos in it
right so at some corporate level they've
accepted that a huge number of the
people going to taco bell are high yeah
and that they will cater to them they
just can't say it in their advertising
yeah it's like those shower massagers
that are clearly not for anything other
than really massaging you know what i'm
saying no i don't know what you're
saying
come on you know what if you don't like
yourself what have you used your shower
massage i'm not i don't have one i'm
just saying you they're they're sold in
like a cvs with the kind of like bulbous
end and it's like oh yeah relax your
muscles in the shower but what we really
know is going on there is hello no
you're the i had to talk no idea what
are you talking about
you know what girl you probably look at
everything like that you're like oh we
all know what those traffic cones are
really for well come on what's the
microphones we're talking into yeah
that's really going on here you look at
everything that way oh look at that
weather stripping oh boy don't get me
started
i'm going to say that a uh
iconic actress i was once having a party
at my home an iconic actress was there i
cannot say the name but an iconic
superstar actress was there and she
asked just a quick for a quick tour of
the house and i was showing her the
house and then i showed her my wife's
closet and there was some a bunch of
shoes on the you know on like a rack and
she no with these shoes i bet you and
your wife have a pretty good time with
these high heels oh my god
to this day i don't know what she's
talking about oh my god i don't know
does she mean i'm wearing them and she's
where or am i taking the heel of a shoe
and shoving it into my
no what am i doing stop don't even
finish whatever right about what she
meant
she meant she wears them and then she's
like sexy time for you no she meant the
two of us doing something with the shoes
and it meant both of us oh and i cannot
name the actress i just can't
you will after i know cause then you're
gonna say oh he just mouthed sally
fields and we all know
is that who it was no it was not uh but
i gave you i sure had you going there
for a second it was not but everything
i've told you was true anyway that's my
story and i'm sticking to it that
actress says how to heal shoved up her
vagina for sure
for starters i'm sorry you guys are
being subtle i'm saying it as it is it's
that's is that what you meant i don't
mean anything like burley's the one that
can look at anything and immediately see
an erotic adventure by the way can i see
one of those combos i'm getting turned
on yeah yeah girly sees a combo and he's
like oh yeah hello they say it's a
pretzel snack with cheese in it but we
all know what it's really for
around a section of the dark web that
gives the real purposes for everyday
things we but i hear moaning from
gourley's office i kick the door down
he's in there with combos all over his
nipples
it's not even real cheese the rap site
came up right as you said that yeah oh
he wants to wrap it up guys guys guys we
have a lot of show today a lot of shows
so let's just stick with that mental
image
girly
uh having
explosive orgasms covered oh come on
pretzels combos because you've gone too
far or not far enough